لكن ماذا حركت الحكومات العراقيه من اجل
هذا الملف الطويل والثقيل فما ينطبق على
ملفات الفساد ينطبق على هذا الملف ايضا
جهات واحزاب وفصائل فاعله متهمه والاقتراب
وليس سهلا بدا الامر منذ 2003 لكن بين
عامين 2006 و 2008 وسعت هذه العمليات
وسجلت في تلك الفتره سجلت في تلك الفتره
عمليات اختفاء واختطاف غزه فتنه الطائفيه
قالت اتهامات ولاحقات الجيش المهدي وفيلق
بدر وقتها قتلنا وخطفا للالاف من سكان
بغداد والبصره الانتماءهم المذهبي فتره
اخرى بين عام 2014
و2/2017 تحرير واراضا عراقيه من تنظيم
داعش مره اخرى الشعبي
الطبيعه تسهم في كشف اثار بعض الجرائم
مقبره جماعيه في محافظه الصلاح الدين تضم
رفه مدنيين قيل انهم اختفوا منذ 50 سنوات
وهذا مختطف سابق وشقيق ومختطفا سابق لدى
داعش سيد احمد الهاشمي يروي تفاصيل الالم
انا من الناس اللي سجن في داعش
ووصلت الى حد القتل بعد اخويا اخذوني بقيت
تقريبا
فتره معينه لا استطيع ذكرها من قد الالم
اللي انا بيها تقريبا يا 15 10 ايام
تقريبا ظليت في سجون داعش في قضاء البعاج
همم التحرير الموصل
قطعت الاخبار بالكامل
عن اخونا وما نعرف همم وين راحوا وهؤلاء
الناس
المشايخ والساده والعمده والضباط
المنتسبين كثيرين كانوا في السجون لم نعلم
انهم شيء لحد هذه اللحظه هم مغيبين
باحتبار
هذا الحديث يتمشى مع بيناته يومين رايتس
واتش اتهامه الميليشيات ومن بينها فيلق
بدر ولواء علي الاكبر وعصائب اهل الحق
وكتائب حزب الله وسرايا الخرساني وجند
الامام مرارا تكرارا تحاول الحكومات فتح
الملف لكن ما الجدول مثلا في عام 2016
اكثر من 600 مفقود خلال معارك ضد داعش في
استقلاويه في الانبار شكلت شكلت لجنه لكن
ماذا عن النتيجه لا نتائج وهذا ما ينقلنا
للنقطه التاليه امين الشيات ليست واحدهها
بقفص الاتهام الشرطه والجيش العراقي ايضا
بناءا على شهادات انه وثقتها المنظمه وهذا
طبعا بجانب الخصومات السياسيه ثمنها باهض
حراره 20 مثال 75 حاله اختطاف موفقه اطلق
سراحه 22 منهم فقط البقيه فما زالوا
مجهولي المصير